and he borrowed my nose to ask it
what's up brandon what's up corner nick
chin uh this is daniel coming at you
from the
beautiful island of guam oh i'm out here
serving my country
but uh i got a quick king of the stinger
for you guys like a shirt
talking about those horror tattoos his
are sick
that's dope we got that
changed damn that's a good word
now you're only cool in october but
that's all right
one of my favorite ones is pennywise oh
my god that's just this thing can
understand it
gang gang buzz buzz dude king and
especially in october you're a real hit
the rest of the holidays get a little
dicey
and then uh sting it if you have kids
that probably scares the [ __ ] out of
kids
i feel like you would get used to it
when you you grow up seeing it all the
time i don't
know that tattoo scares me at 37 years
old
that could be scary for a child man yeah
you can't hug a child with that kind of
arm
that [ __ ] is but maybe in guam they
different yeah
they're not little [ __ ] that it
tattoo is so
good that artwork is insane in guam
they're probably different man look up
something scary and guam
anybody ever heard no that's mexico i'm
saying do they have something like that
in guam
oh yeah i'm sure anybody ever been to
guam here
i might have been there might have been
i don't know where i've been these days
something's scary from guam
some like tall tale they got you know oh
they got haunted houses
dude are haunted houses still popping
during covet or can we not do that they
have like drive-through
ones where it's like a haunted truck
yeah i'm out
you uh in arizona they're doing them
back home really yeah
oh damn we're there next week i'm not
going to a haunted house
what else do i say you look like you
just got off
[Laughter]
guam you can go back in time so if you
did something you could regret go back
in time and fix it
by the way for people in guam you can do
a little you can go back about 40
minutes i said local residents dude
maybe we should do a
a podcast trip there go to guam doug
hey so i do remember now it came back to
me uh oh there he goes
when i was a kid no i'm serious that's a
fake story no remember greatest american
hero
nope he had a red suit on and he had an
afro but it was a white guy
he flew but he's one of the many
gladiators no he could never land though
he would fall and start
tumbling no no so my mom would perm my
hair and she made my outfit oh you're
older than us yeah but what does he look
like
uh greatest american hero oh never you
know
it's not home believe it or not i'm
walking on it
that was the theme song that's right
that's what i was when i was a kid
you guys don't remember this how was
your outfit though yes
thank you that man i mean come on now
like richard simmons he was a superhero
but he couldn't he couldn't
like land richard simms looked like the
rock that boy hey
fine though yeah the girl is really hot
that's the og amer
captain america the greatest american
hero
there you go he looks like uh have you
ever seen the movie sinister
that's the sign that sinister leaves on
all the what
it is yeah hmm it's scary with ethan
hawk right jerry
yeah that's scary that got voted uh
scary movie yep
what did over the exorcist yeah yeah no
way you've seen sinister seniors are not
that scary i don't think
i was scared part two is good too i've
never seen it i can't
you never seen it no you just said it's
not scary i know
oh it's similar sinister's a great movie
i was guessing
i like the new it's too i was watching
it last night my girl fell asleep
i was scared yeah the worst movie was
the new michael myers the latest one the
halloween from last year
that's what you get is that what jamie
that's what you get for watching
so bad terrible so bad
it wasn't even scary have you seen the
new it's though oh they're good
god damn they're good i don't know hold
it it's good to still holds up over time
damn bad acting but whatever i don't
know man i gotta freaking do four years
in the persian gulf coming up
i'm in the navy oh yeah
i respect it thanks man appreciate my
service
yeah i appreciate my appreciation
[Music]
is